and you've dealt largely with great
icons this is a buried story how did you
come to unque well you know I've always
loved stories about producers and
songwriters but this is buried a layer
or two even deeper and there was no map
for this film at all there was no brief
it was what could this film be and the
first thing I did was I did 50 oral
histories of backup singers just to
figure out how that whole world worked
and instantly it became 3d to me you
know I figured out the stories and the
themes and the characters and I saw what
the film could be you selected about
half a dozen or so how did you come to
terms and create this I mean it was
difficult I mean this was an incredibly
difficult film to edit first of all I
had to come up with an idea of what what
was my definition of a backup singer
because it could spiral off in so many
directions you could talk about girl
groups or talk about Nashville singers
to talk about male singers or you know
on and on and on and I felt like I had
to come up with a very specific
definition and come up with a group of
ladies who came from different
generations whose stories echoed each
other so they all kind of create a
broader meta arc of the backup singer
but at the same time they all made
different decisions and had different
twists and turns so you know some of
whom are a little tortured by the back
up world and others for whom you know
it's it's a state of grace it was really
about establishing a tone with this film
and just riding that tone and that tone
comes from those ladies I mean that's
soulful a little bittersweet beautiful
tone I just wanted to kind of stay in
that zone there's an almost musical
structure to the way you weave present
and past and performance as well I just
started collecting songs I might listen
to the radio endlessly and you know my
other producer Kate Rodgers and
everybody working on it we were all
listening to the radio rediscovering
backup vocals and songs we all knew you
know and it was constantly this oh my
god I never realized that Steely Dan
song with that Peter Gabriel song or
that whatever song
was based on a backup singer so the
interviews themselves didn't give you a
list to come to get me person pieces but
you know not because honestly backup
singers for the most part they're
they're the least historic museum zve
all because a lot of times their
encounter with a song was a three hours
session thirty years ago you know so
they're they you know they always say I
can't remember what I sang on you know
they occasionally have these very
specific great stories but they were
doing sometimes three or four sessions a
day you know nine out of ten of those
were flops and disappeared you know it's
just difficult for them to put it into
any kind of historical context so when I
came up with this list of songs I
started to come together with characters
and I wanted characters that connected
with big songs at times too I put
together a mix CD you know of like an
ideal soundtrack this is before we
started editing and tried to tell the
story through music and I found found it
really helpful because you know music
for me and in my music documentaries is
not adornments and it's not wallpaper
and I see music users wallpaper all the
time you know that the music is the
story and that every song in this film
is a story beat or a character beat and
that was really important to me so it
doesn't feel just plopped in by an
editor or something you know it's it
actually helps tell the story I think
one of the things that haunts viewers
after they've seen this I've seen this a
number of times is trying to figure out
why these women didn't have solo careers
and I'm wondering now that you've heard
the stories and worked with them any
thoughts of your own about what happened
well the difference between a lead
singer the backup singer is a hit yeah I
mean the bit that's a little glib but I
mean there's something to that you know
I feel like in certain cases somebody
like Mary Clayton
if she had had a hit on one of those Lou
Adler albums I mean he'd he produced
tapestry his next album was Mary
Clayton's album and if she'd had hit on
that she'd be Chaka Khan or Patti
LaBelle it was somebody like that
because she has the talent of those
singers another thing I've been thinking
about is that
backup singers I mean Bishan certainly
is is a huge part of an Italian tie
think it's probably a second or third on
the list of reasons people become stars
but ambition is a big one maybe first on
the list and these singers are so good
and so naturally good and have been so
good since they were children that I
don't think they ever had to work that
hard at it they were always just great
and when it came that time for them to
flex their ambition and really you know
do all the kind of dirty work you have
to do to become a star I I don't think a
lot of them had the stomach for it and
you know but Steffi Alexander says in
the film a lot of us are not great self
promoters and I think that might be part
of the reason and there are a whole
bunch of other you know it's sting talks
about it to it there's a an element of
fate at one point I had a montage of
reasons why backup singers were saying
their solo records didn't take off and
it was stuff like the week my record
came out my A&R guy got busted for Coke
the week my record came out the
record-pressing plant burnt down the
month my record came out the record got
banned in England because there's a word
that was accidentally profane in England
you know just crazy ridiculous reasons
and you know for these people that was
often the hurdle that kind of stopped
their careers in their tracks you know
maybe if they were fiercely ambitious
they could have could have overcome
those and kept going but the backup
world is not a bad place to to remain I
mean the waters for instance said to me
that you know we've sung behind these
artists and they might have one hit and
they'd come and have a three-year career
or a five-year career and then they
vanish and we have nice houses we have
families we have children that we've put
in through good schools we get paid to
do what we love and we've been doing it
for 50 years you know and there's
something that's a ok with that you know
there's something that's great about
just that sense of this is an admirable
job